In reference to the glucose meter, the glucometer on your site you have an asterisk at the bottom that says it's not appropriate for blood cancer. So here's the question I talked about before.
The glucometer is not what's not important for blood cancer, but just checking your glucose on a weekly basis is not important for the leukemias.
I have to change this because when I say blood cancer, I'm really talking about the leukemias.
Because most leukemias are not fed by glucose.
It's still important to keep your glucose in a healthy range, whether you have cancer or not, whether you have leukemia or not.
But it's more important to have your glucose in a healthy range if you have a solid tumor.
So that is a lymphoma. I talked to somebody about this the other day.
Well, lymphoma is technically a blood cancer, but lymphoma is kind of that in between cancer because there's it becomes a solid cancer.
So lymphoma is kind of leukemia that has become a solid, solid tumor.
So lymphoma, yes, you can feed a lukoba lymphoma through the glycolysis pathway.
We need through the breakdown of glucose, so it's beneficial to keep your glucose at the lowest level as possible.
And if you have a leukemia, is it is important to check your blood glucose on a regular basis as it is as it would be if you had a solid tumor.
The answer is no, in my opinion, it's important if you have a solid tumor, whether it be brain cancer, breast cancer, you know any cancer other than the leukemias.
And then it's important to check your blood glucose when you can, you know, a lot of you guys are getting a CBC and a complete metabolic panel on a monthly basis as your blood glucose is better than the 80s.
Well, you don't need a glucometer then, you know, but for those who I haven't been doing that and I do want to, you know, I'm trying to keep a really good diet.
You know, check my glucose levels, then then get a little glucometer like this, they're really handy.
The question on the clinic, cometer test, you were where to buy, I understand at the bottom of it says it's not appropriate. Okay, so that's what I read by that.
It's beneficial for everybody, it's not as important for leukemia patients.